- [Voiceover] So we're asked to choose
the equation that can represent
the hyperbola graphed below.
And so this is the hyperbola graphed
in blue and I encourage
you to pause the video
and figure out which of these equations
are represented by the graph here.
Alright, so let's think about it.
This graph opens to
the left and the right.
Well, I guess, the first
thing we could realize,
it's centered at zero.
So definitely, it's just going to have
the form, x squared and y squared over
two different things equaling one.
And we know that it opens
to the left and the right.
You can think of it opens
along the x-direction
and so we know that the x-term is going
to be positive here,
which tells us that the
y-term is going to be negative.
And we know that the vertices here are
five to the right of the center
and five to the left of the center
and so since the distance
from the vertices
to the center is five in
the horizontal direction,
we know that this right over here
is going to be five squared or 25.
And this we don't quite know, just yet.
I just call this a squared.
We don't know what a is.
Now let's look at these choices here.
X squared over 25 minus y squared
over nine equals one.
Well, that seems to match the pattern
that I was able to
generate really quickly,
just looking at the
graph, so I like this one.
This has the x-term being negative.
So this graph over
here, this would open up
up and down, not to
the left and the right,
so we could rule this out.
This one over here. This
has x squared over nine.
That would imply that our x-intercepts
are plus or minus three
to the right and left
of the center, not five.
Clearly, they aren't plus or minus three
so we could rule this one out.
This one has the y-term being positive
and the x-term being negative,
so once again, this
would open up and down.
So we could rule that one out as well.
And so our first choice
that we like that matched
our pattern, we could
feel pretty good about it.
Now if you wanted to verify the nine
or if you want, you might want to try out
some other points or solve some points,
if it wasn't multiple
choice but in this case,
we are able to pick out.
This is the only one that even matches
the general structure that
we were able to deduce.